Fully believed that the fundamental myth
of the human being was the myth and the
myth from a broader perspective is a
failed hero's story,
so the eatable myth is the myth of a man
who develops who grows up,
but then accidentally becomes too close
to his mother,
sleeps with her,
he doesn't know who she is,
and as a consequence blinds himself and
there's a.
there's a,
there's a warning about human
development going wrong in that story
and I think that Freud put his finger on
it extraordinarily well because human
beings have a very long period of
dependency and one of the things that
you do see in clinical practice is that
many people's problems are associated
with their inability to break free of
their family,
like they're consumed by the family
drama,
right?
They can't get beyond what happened to
them in their family.
They're stuck in the past.
It's,
and that's,
that's equivalent symbolically speaking,
you might say to the idea of being too
close to your mother of,
of,
of the boundaries being improperly
specified,
and that happens far more often than
anyone would like to think.
As I said,
for I thought it was a universal,
but you see,
he had a different idea and his idea was
that it wasn't the failed hero story
that was the universal human myth.
It was the successful hero's story.
And that's a big difference.
I could seriously a big difference
because the successful hero story is
member in sleeping beauty.
You may remember this in the Disney
movie,
the evil queen traps the prince in a
dungeon and she's not gonna let them out
till he's old.
Right?
And so there's this comical scene where
she's down in the dungeon,
he's all in chains and she's laughing at
him,
telling him what his future is going to
be like.
She's quite evil and you know,
she,
she paints this wonderful picture of him
being freed in like 80 years and
hobbling out of the castle on his,
his horse that's so old,
he can barely stand up in him with gray
hair.
And,
and you know,
she,
she recites this story of his eventual
triumphant departure from the castle as
a old and decrepit man.
And she has a great laugh about it and
it's nice.
You know,
it's a real punchy story.
It's really something wonderful for
children,
that story and um,
he gets free of the,
of the shackles and the things that
freedom or three little female ferries,
the positive aspect of the feminine that
frees him from the dungeon.
It's so.
It's very interesting and very accurate
from a psychological perspective.
It's the negative element of the
feminine that encapsulates him in the
dungeon and it's the positive element of
the feminine that frees him.
And then he,
he has a queen.
The Evil Queen is not very happy when he
escapes.
You may remember that she stands on top
of her castle tower and starts to spin
off cosmic sparks.
I mean,
she's quite the creature in opt in flame
and then she turns into a dragon and she
then the prince has to fight with her in
order to make contact with sleeping
beauty and an awakened her from her
comatose existence as her unconscious
existence and a wants a brilliant.
It's a brilliant representation of a
successful hero myth.
He,
he doesn't end up staying in an unholy
relationship with his mother.
Let's say he escapes and then conquers
the worst thing that can be imagined and
is ennobled by that and that as a
consequences able to wake the slumbering
feminine from its coma and that's a
union story and that's the story that he
juxtaposed against Freud,
Freud thought of religious phenomena as
part of an old cult tide.
That would be,
that would drown rationale rationality.
That's why Freud was so valiantly
antireligious and you thought,
no,
it's not the case.
You're throwing the baby out with the
bathwater.
There's something profound and central
to the hero myth and union clinical work
is essentially the awakening of the hero
myth in the in the analysis and in the
in the client or the patient to
conceptualize yourself as that which can
confront chaos and triumph and that
that's associated with an ennobling of
the Sea of consciousness and the
establishment of pop.
Proper positive relationships between
male and female.
And you know,
I'm a skeptical person.
I'm a very,
very skeptical person and I've tried
with every trick.
I have to put a lever underneath young
story and lifted up and disrupt it and
I.
I can't do it.
I think he was right and that Freud was
wrong.
I mean,
I have great respect for Freud.
I think he got the progam problem
diagnosed very,
very nicely and in my clinical work,
I see the phenomena that Freud described
emerge continually,
constantly that the best.
If you're interested in that,
there's a documentary you should watch.
I may have mentioned it before.
I think it's the best documentary ever
made.
Certainly the best one I've ever seen.
It's called crumb and it's about a
underground cartoonists.
Robert Crumb,
who,
who was part of the hippie movement in,
although he hated hippies,
he was part of the hippie movement in,
in the sixties,
in San Francisco,
and started the entire underground
comic.
What culture that that manifested itself
eventually in,
in graphic novels,
there's quite a significant figure from
the perspective of popular art and a
very,
very intelligent man and also I would
say a hero,
although a very bent and depraved and
warped one.
Someone very acutely aware of his own
shadow and the documentary outlines his
attempts to escape from his absolutely
dreadful mother and the failure of his
two brothers to do the same thing,
one of whom ended up as a street beggar
in San Francisco and the other who drank
furniture Polish and died six months
after the documentary was produced.
It's an unbelievably shocking
documentary.
It's the only piece of film that I've
ever seen that captures Friday and
pathology.
I've never seen anything because he
can't see it generally,
unless you're in a clinical situation,
unless you know the details of someone's
lives,
the personal intimate details,
you cannot communicate it,
but the documentary who made the film
was Robert's way golf,
if I remember correctly,
was a friend of the crumbs and so he got
access in a way that no one else would
have and they're also very forthright
and forthcoming about their situation in
general.
I would highly recommend that it's.
It's a real punch.
If you want to know how a rapist thinks,
like if you actually want to know
because maybe you don't want to know.
In fact,
you probably don't want to know,
right,
because do you really want to know that?
Because to understand that means to put
yourself in that position and to
understand it.
If you really want to know how a serial
sexual Predator thinks and why,
if you watch crum and you pay attention,
you'll know and that's only a tiny bit
of what the film has to offer.
It's really quite remarkable.